thank you
[Music]
did you guys hear the Supreme Court has
just struck down the student loan
forgiveness program we did hear about
that so it's not Biden's fault it's the
Supreme Court's fault
yeah dominating uh it's not gonna happen
so you saw that coming though so now if
you have student loan debt it's not
going to be forgiven it's back on you
know what's weird though
it's only 430 million that's all it
takes to to take well the 400 billion
billion almost billion okay
May weather Clifford himself yeah
because yeah if it was 430 million I'm
like we said way [__] more to Ukraine
and I'm like that's all that's gonna
take I was like there's no way 430
million is going to cover all the
student loans that's nothing right
dude oh 430 billion I didn't read it
right 60 right now that are still paying
that [__] off yeah isn't that crazy well
they shouldn't have [__] buried
themselves with degrees you poor
educated [__]
[__] idiots
degree it was called psychology
um that's pretty bad that's a hard one
it's pretty bad you know why it's bad
though is because you don't yeah you
don't make anything with just a
bachelor's yeah so like
I mean most things you don't right with
the Bachelors yeah teaching how do you
guys feel about that concept though of
like taking a loan out because it isn't
one side it's like well you took out
that loan so you owe it and then what's
the other side I don't even know it
should be free yeah because you're
benefiting this this world by Society by
contributing and whatever making School
free in general it's like having kids
right like um you're benefiting the
world like our our country because those
kids will go be productive members of
society hopefully so we give you tax
credits to have kids yeah yeah yeah yeah
some places they're paying you to have
kids because they need yeah yeah
population right or like marriage like
you get a tax break for having you know
getting into marriage because they're
it's better for
community and Society so it would be for
like citizens then I'm assuming like if
you're studying abroad then you take on
the debt and you might go back to your
mother country so
the tuition should exist for
non-citizens
is that how it works then
they already paid a premium so some
colleges they uh but yeah but for the
concept of free school not free school
then you would only charge the
immigrants is what they want yeah well
technically is free school for
um lower middle class and you know like
we got financial aid and then the
financial aid was pretty damn good yeah
but once you go to four years pretty
expensive yeah yeah if you go to a UC
it's like 30 G's a year they definitely
need to make something illegal in the
marketing of specific Majors that you
will make any money at all right it's
like your return is not gonna be because
the part that I do find shady is um
there's like this graph that shows
um
like
I think over the years how much the dean
and how much the admissions cost has
gone yeah and it goes like this but then
School resources and like the actual
School itself and how much is expanding
it's like this so it's not like as the
as the payment to get in is getting
astronomical it's not like the size of
the school is also
you know it's just the [__] Dean used
to make 200 Grand and now some Deans
make 800 Grand a year and it's packed
with just more admin people and it's not
really like the payment is really
benefiting the kids yeah I mean if the
school's making money that's different
than if the students that leave make
money
I heard that um the quality of Education
changed too so like more people do have
degrees right but then like for example
to be a certified like physical
therapist now you need at least a
Masters or even in the 90s if you had a
bachelor's you could already start
practicing yeah so then like there's a
lot of degrees like that where it's even
more expensive in the investors in PT
yeah so like in in I would say like the
mid-2000s they flipped a lot of those
where it's like now you got to have
Beyond a bachelor's to actually get a
job because there's a surplus of
Bachelor holders and it doesn't have the
same weight or like there's just more
[__] to it right but then the university
system is a massive money maker and then
they do
um put a lot of money into attracting
students because like if the sports
program is good if there's like a lot of
fun [__] they always got to spend on new
buildings and then like a lot of the
money goes toward the marketing and
getting people in versus like the
quality of Education yeah way more
towards the marketing with this thing
that got struck down even though like
the headline is oh they struck this
thing down and it looks bad where the
details of what they struck down
actually going to be a good plan
um that's a really good question I don't
know how it would have been applied
because
um basically they were they it's
basically a big a big pause has happened
I also hate [__] words like that you
know they always like the way they frame
being struck down or am I [__]
annihilated
talk about what it is before you get me
all emotionally riled up I can't even
yeah things like that where they're like
hey this bill is going to help homeless
people but at the cost of a million of
these other things and it won't work so
then it's like the thing about it I
think for students is they're like okay
like they've already paused student
loans for two years right so with this
they were going to permanently cancel up
to twenty thousand dollars in loans so a
lot of people they're counting on that
nothing and for a lot of people that's a
big chunk right so it just depends
really that's true because if you're
doing like a medical or like anything
where you uh by the time you graduate
you're like in 200k in debt like
Pharmacy or certain other things that's
nothing but like let's say if you're
just graduating with a psychology degree
from Cal States 20 grand is probably
half right yeah yeah and that's another
thing too is like State schools some of
them can be pretty affordable
and then you know you go to like a
higher tier one like USC like I don't
know if it's like how much it is now but
at one point it was like 80 grand a year
so you do that four years yeah
yeah that's a lot but it's like Medical
School bro yeah
it is but I don't know
um you know some people like you know
universities are interesting subject
right because like it's like some people
go to become professionals like you're
going in to like be a engineer a doctor
you know like you actually need to go to
a accredited system and then you have to
pass the these different yeah and then
you maybe you want to be a researcher
like that's your thing right so you
probably want to work at a university
but then if you're just in one of the
humanities or like anthropology or like
yeah like
I mean that's just like good luck dude
if you figure it out that's good for you
but yeah chances are nah dude it's not
gonna work that's that's meant for like
let's say you're a trust fund kid right
and you just want to be a philosopher
yeah then then yeah go to prestigious
University and like lecture all day and
like be a brainiac but then for the rest
of us like if you're from the working
class middle class even
it's really a worthless degree but
that's also the fault of our own Society
for stigmatizing blue-collar jobs
exactly like we [__] up by making
those guys not cool we stick with guys
work bro yeah like like people make fun
of people for like uber driving and [__]
which is [__] up yes seriously we're
working at a grocery store exactly and
grocery stores pay good dude like well
in California because they're like a lot
of them are unionized and like dude dude
most broke boy jobs pay really [__]
well there's a guy trying to [__] me
yesterday on Grindr who was who worked
who managed a grocery store yeah they
did what it's this is really funny oh go
ahead no no I was I was gonna say
anything good so like we okay so so me
and Bart we have friends out of high
school who decided College isn't for me
and I'm gonna do blue collared [__]
right and we also have friends who are
like
snobbery I'm going to [__] USC I'm
going to this school whatever right
the funny thing is all of those
blue-collar friends are crushing it
right now at our age absolutely couple
hundred thousand a year yeah and then
some of these other snooty snobby guys
like they're not doing well like like I
hear stories like crush it dude yeah the
air conditioner people HVAC oh my God
yeah yeah dude my buddy he was a
construction guy and everyone was giving
them [__] for like not going to college
or whatever
now he's like damn near a foreman
building Sofi stadium and [__] wow
killing it damn yeah especially once
you're in Union like as a long shoreman
or something oh dude they make more than
doctors they make like 300 400 000 a
year but how'd the construction guys
make any money building so far we have
to pay a hundred dollars for parking
every [__] dude
he's your whole checkup dude dude he was
telling me the guys that that do like
the the welding on the top of the
building
like five or six of them die
and like how they bid for the jobs so
it's like how how so the company or
whatever was building sofa is like all
right we're gonna go with these
contractors or these contractors is
based on how many less deaths they could
like say that they're be able to have so
it's like okay this company has we'll
promise you four deaths and this company
is like we'll promise you like six
they'll bid they'll they'll go with a
company that could provide really phrase
it like that yeah dude it's crazy and I
was like what the [__] and these guys
are from Germany and they're like spider
webs and they're climbing all the way
all of the thing to like have to
negotiate but those guys obviously get
paid crazy amounts of money because as
they should man you know what's funny
well it's not funny but statistically
those jobs are way more dangerous than
being a cop
that's funny yeah because like you think
like you're a cop you're getting shot at
all day it's a dangerous job it is a
danger you can be a cop in a rural town
too yeah but like crab crabbers are the
most crap most dangerous job yeah the
most the deep sea Fisher guys [__]
Deadliest Catch guys crazy [__] you're
guaranteed that like some of your Crews
gonna die like guaranteed every year
dangerous is the Ice Road Truckers dude
we're just going through those all those
shows support on the list chopped I'm
telling us here you know what's another
one
um
they're so extreme
that's a big one because you're like in
scuba gear and you're just [__]
because they they like fix oil rigs all
that right they're in the middle of
nowhere yeah metal ring workers too more
than that yeah nordstream demolitionists
do the trade school guys also get their
student loans uh forgiven Too part as
part of this thing or is it just like
the universe
they paid it off the first few months
dude all the homies that became
mechanics they're killing it bro that's
what I'm saying trade school is pretty
sick because you're like literally
learning what you're gonna do directly
versus University go for four years you
have all this theoretical knowledge and
then you get to your job and then they
have to retrain yourself that's why like
I wish if they were to propose something
like this they pair it with oh yeah
we're gonna forgive this debt but we're
also gonna fix what got them in this
debt in the first place which is
misinformation of your own future like
you can't they're making these decisions
at times where they don't have a lot of
info and then when they finish it
they're like I wish someone told me and
everyone thinks that because you have a
degree now you're worth more so you have
all these snobby-ass [__] 21 year
olds that just graduated and they're too
good to work uh entry-level job right
and those guys they should have 100K
salary being a manager when you never
[__] work the day right yeah
I know so many people like there's so
many people yeah it's like you haven't
had one [__] job you don't even know
how to work at like a Fast Food Spot
yeah and then now oh I have a degree I
deserve 80k a year right that's like you
kind are you gonna [__] manage people
when you don't even know how to do that
and you have all these trade school
people that literally are the jobs that
build the [__] nation and we're just
gonna act like oh that's that's broke
boy [__] right yeah but I mean okay in
the Asian Community too right like it's
kind of it's It's it kind of because the
parents would like work these Blue
Collar jobs and then they would force
their kids to not
do the same [__] right and then they
push them into becoming professionals
something else yeah yeah or something
else right and then they disown you when
you want to be an oceanographer but then
like I bet they can make good money huh
my dad my dad was funny because when I
was when I was growing up every like
year of my life he'd be like I'm telling
you just do x-ray I don't do [__] at
work I went to school for two years it's
so easy he's like all your uncles are
gonna be there you don't even have to do
anything because you just push buttons
he's been telling me that forever my mom
talked [__] about blue collar though and
she's like you got to go to White Collar
do whatever whatever and then like I
don't even [__] do I got it for your
degree I don't even [__] use it yeah
at all and then yeah like Joe was saying
all of our friends I had blue collar
jobs that stayed in the union and like
they did the whole like Track by the
time they're like 10 years in they have
the cushions job best benefits a lot of
them end up opening their own companies
yeah and then they turn into actual like
entrepreneurs and business owners with a
really good skill it's like yeah even if
you don't need to do something with it
yeah and they have a bunch of capital to
do something with it and they get to
work immediately after finishing that's
the best thing they get tons of benefits
they're secure they get like [__]
truck credits have you heard of that
stuff credit yeah like some of the
construction guys like they'll they'll
either use a truck from like the company
or they'll give them a stipend to be
able to pay for their own truck that
they could use for work and it's like
they get hooked up after you put in your
time though but people don't want to put
them yeah man yeah trade school is a
freaking Jam dude and we spent so many
years making fun of these things so yeah
this is the result that is but why do
why do you think we have this whole like
oh it's like they're it's not good
enough for like leave that has to do
with universities trying to shop people
into their school definitely the
marketing it's like it's the it's the
culture too though yeah it's a class
concept it's like oh that's the higher
class road yeah because if you think
about it right like blue collar folks
sometimes get paid more than like
teachers but then the title of being a
teacher for middle class is like yeah
you'll get like 40K a year but then
you're more respected than a than a
maybe a guy that works in a factory
that's making 150 that's the part that
needs to change that part right there
yes even people make fun of people
working at McDonald's and [__] yeah
seriously and McDonald's if you want to
own a McDonald's you have to go work at
one yeah it's like [__] like that people
just don't even know what the [__]
going on I mean just just the fact that
the the uh double standard of making fun
of anyone that's working yeah seriously
it's like dude this food's working dude
it's like we're all kind of slaves yeah
in different ways right like even small
business owners like you're slave to
your customer and at the same time like
you if everyone has to work to survive
in some capacity like no one's doing
this just for fun like you can be doing
it for passion but you still have to do
it because we're not trust fund kids and
even they have to figure out a way to
maintain their wealth or else they'll
squander it right so it's like the
system is all rigged in a way where like
unless you're one of the Rothschilds
[__] dude be a Rothschild hack quick
yeah change your name
[Music]
oh